bonjour à tous cette semaine je vais
vous parler d'un film qui s'appelle
buried qui veut dire enterré qui a été
réalisé par Rodrigo Cortes en 2010 alors
pour vous raconter un peu l'histoire du
film cette histoire d'un chauffeur de
camions basé en Irak qui va se retrouver
du jour au lendemain qui va se réveiller
dans un enterré dans un cercueil en bois
[Musique]
avec un une lampe torche un couteau un
briquet et un téléphone portable c'est
vrai que sinon on pourrait rien voir
dans le cercueil c'est un film qui est
très oppressant parce que pendant une
heure et demie on a l'impression d'être
enfermé avec le comédien dans ce
cercueil là où je trouve que le film est
intéressant que le réalisateur a fait un
énorme travail c'est qu'il arrive à nous
tenir en haleine pendant 1h30 avec un
seul comédien un seul décor et trois
quatre valeurs de plans différentes ça
me rappelle un petit peu ce qu'avait
fait Alfred Hitchcock dans le film
livebot en 1944 c'est à dire un huis
clos avec très peu de comédiens et très
peu de décors donc je vous conseille
d'aller voir ce film parce que justement
ce concept là est très très intéressant
[Musique]